un accord de paix qualifié d'historique
et une nouvelle avancée dans la
stratégie de washington et tel aviv
visant à renforcer les relations entre
l'état hébreu et les alliés des
etats-unis au moyen-orient citoyens
d'israël
je suis heureux de vous informer que
nous allons conclure un autre accord de
paix avec un autre pays arabe avec le
bahreïn
ils s'ajoutent à l'accord de paix
historique avec les émirats arabes unis
il nous a fallu 26 ans pour conclure le
deuxième accord de paix avec un pays
arabe
et il y en aura d'autres c'est une
nouvelle ère de paix nous avons investi
dans la paix pendant de nombreuses
années et maintenant la paix va investir
en nous et nous conduire à des
investissements très importants dans
l'économie israélienne de nouvelles
alliances avec pour principal objectif
isoler l'iran dans la région la corse à
lui notamment par l'egypte a aussi
provoqué une vague de réprobations le
hamas dénonce une agression c'est un
coup de poignard pour l'autorité
palestinienne et pour téhéran bahreïn se
rend tout simplement complice d'israël
les dirigeants de bahreïn seront
désormais complices des crimes du régime
sioniste comme une menace constante pour
la sécurité de la région et du monde
musulman
pour donald trump il s'agit d'un succès
diplomatique précieux à moins de huit
semaines de l'élection présidentielle
l'accord doit être officiellement signé
à la maison blanche la semaine prochaine